yeah hello welcome to this video yeah
this will be the first video about um T
Steel chess tournament
2013 yeah this
year the T Steel tournament is probably
the second most important of the year it
is the most um yeah
prestigious um I think reoccurring event
that we have each year but this year
we've got the candidates tournament in
London in about two month two or 3 month
and of course this would be the most
important but otherwise tataa steel is
probably the event that um the top guys
want to win most yeah it's um very
strong field it's not as strong as in
previous years I would say sometimes um
yeah some years um before it it was even
a bit stronger but still it's a very
very strong field um yeah the first
round has been played
today in all three groups and
um I went through um all games quickly
of of the three three groups and decided
to do a quick recap of all games of um
of the top group so um I don't get into
those games um very deeply but sort of
um do a round report so that you know
what was going
on okay um let's start here with the
first game we had some heavyweight um
pairings in the first round we have
Carson against Karana here and let's see
what what happened Carson playing
C4 and Karana going G6 C4 is um
one one of those moves that um can be
classified as an anti-g grunfeld move
move and we see immediately with E4 that
Caron is preventing all gron Fels yeah
and here um karona takes a chance to
steer the game into um
somewhat yeah yeah irregular maybe too
strong word but rarely play channels he
plays E5 instantly
um yeah playing against white going D4
white could play D4 even here to open up
the position um but um it's not so
dangerous for black um instead cson
decides to go for a Clos setup Bishop G7
and now G3 this is the typical B vinck
Center there are quite a lot of setups
called B vinck but this is
um the typical C4 E4 Pawn tandem that
the um yeah the go maybe The Godfather
father of modern Russian chess um has
invented to control
D5 okay D6 Bishop oh no Knight E2 first
and now Karana plays C5 and this is
really a bit of a spoil sport
move it um
prevents D4 forever and sets up a
completely symmetrical Center and here
it is difficult to um to make anything
out of this position really it's a very
slow maneuvering game we see what
happens it's more or less
symmetrical and um we see that cson gets
um a bit of play on The Queen side with
B4 but it's uh it's not much
really H3 and um some
exchanges and black um
has this idea getting the Knight to D4
and it's very difficult for why to avoid
um an exchange of this Knight so white
will probably take this Knight at some
point because it's simply too
strong Let's uh just continue a couple
of
moves and F5 yeah black um yeah strikes
first here this is the only um Pawn
break left in the position F5 or
F4 the thing uh about those Pawn breaks
is that whoever is playing it um is
allowing the other side some activity
with with the bishop if black plays F5
you see that now that CS
takes a couple of moves later and now
his Bishop is opened but um F5 opens
lines for the Rooks and uh therefore
black has got some
activity
so the G file is a possible idea or E
form if all circumstances work for black
you could even break with this
move yeah okay D5 is a good square and
black probably intends to get some
activity going on on the king side I
think the position is uh is very
equal yeah this is an active
move black advances in the
center but
um white can answer with F4 and uh sort
of keep the position
closed now um it's interesting to see
what black is playing he takes on F3
which is the yeah the safe move um there
was also the possibility to go E3 which
looks um very tempting at first s
let's say queen queen here or G2 I don't
know um but this looks very good with
this Pawn but the question is if this uh
Pawn is really um such a great
achievement if white goes let's say
queen to F3 Rook to E2 it is safely
blockaded and maybe white can even go G4
after um careful
preparation so this is maybe risky and
um therefore he just took
here yeah and in this position white um
enjoys the slight Edge because of this
Pawn but we've got opposite color
Bishops and it's
um very difficult to make any decent
progress yeah
here after all these
exchanges it is completely
equal and here the game worth a g drawn
yeah not the most exciting game this um
kind of setup here is
um yeah is RAR producing really exciting
chess C4 E4 um is not that um dull I
mean but if black um gets to play this
complete complete symmetry it it really
gets very closed if black would play
Knight C6 or something then this is much
more interesting battle okay so not uh
not very
exciting Let's uh check Anand against
Nakamura another heavyweight uh
match and we've got a French defense
Nakamura plays all kinds of openings so
it uh certainly wasn't easy for for
vishy to do any
preparation got a French as mentioned
and the classical variation Bishop B4 is
um sort of out of fashion nowadays the
the
winner mostly because of uh check the
queen G4 line which is yeah notoriously
complicated but uh there are very few
players who want to go into this while
Knight F6 uh enjoys a very good
reputation nowadays it's very difficult
for white to find
anything um he played um E5 here arnard
which is um maybe the more testing move
according to um Theory nowadays but this
um of course can easily change Bishop
G5 um black has
um more than one good alternative D
takes E4 is very solid and Bishop B4 is
the sharp MCAT variation which also
seems fine for black so the classical
French is a good opening E5 I mean it
never was a bad opening but but it is in
excellent shape nowadays okay F4 C5
Knight F3 Knight C6 Bishop E3 this is um
the main line of this uh 4 E5 the the
steinet line and here black has um a
multitude of options the move that sort
of brought all this inter fession is
Bishop E7 here which Nakamura didn't
play he played um very sharp line he
took and played Queen B6 um this is um
also interesting way to play for black
it is risky though we will see white um
is sacrificing the
pawn and black grabs it yeah Black's
counter play is um amongst others based
on U this pin idea Bishop to
B5 and now A6 yeah Bishop B4 is another
idea um but this is interesting it
immediately Returns the pawn in this
fashion but um black has somehow um yeah
manage to get rid of the light Square
Bishop which is always a dangerous
attacking piece in in French
structures um yeah at the cost of a pawn
but black has two Bishops and um if he's
able to neutralize White's um activity
he will have a good position check now
gives a
check and returns this was designed
to um yeah put the bishop on a worse
position compared to D4 on D4 it
protected the Knight for example and
also blocked the D Pawn on F2 it is
somewhat
worse Bishop to
B6 Queen
C8 yeah all this looks um somewhat shaky
but um this um on the other hand is um a
relatively forced line
which Nakamura certainly prepared as
mentioned he has played this before in
tournament chess and in Rapid chess so
it is actually a line where you would
think that Anand has uh something
prepared of course it's not easy to
guess the exact opening that Nakamura is
playing but um the French is something
that that he did play so it's not like
he suddenly played I know the Latvian
Gambit or something and um it's
um if you look at this it doesn't really
seem like white uh has anything
prepared and um you can even question if
black um isn't um even more comfortable
already Queen
C6 black has two Bishops and what does
white have um of course he's um quite
well centralized with the queen on D4
but um other than that it's pretty much
nothing he's very stable with those
pieces well it's not that stable but for
the moment it is okay and this bishop
isn't doing so much at the
moment yeah and I think
um we have a repetition and the draw now
yeah this is um quite
um quite a short game and not very
interesting the only interesting fact is
that arold again didn't have any um
anything active interesting prepared
against uh this opening or let's say if
you don't prepare it maybe you can come
up with something over the board but he
didn't yeah the world champion is in a
Long crisis already for a couple of uh
month even years like one and a half
years or so and this is another pretty
unspectacular game where you can only
question if maybe Nakamura could have
gone for more but he's not the kind of
player um that doesn't take his chances
probably um there is
nothing okay next game aronian against
van
v interestingly enough we have a king's
Indian which is uh um yeah really
surprising from from Luke um he played
the Kings Indian um years ago but I
thought he had abandoned it okay and
aronian goes for the H3 line the this
has more than one name it's
um often called the makagon of
line and sometimes also it is associated
with uh bagirov who played it um lots of
times okay E5 D5 Knight H5 H3 is um has
got more than one idea the the main idea
is to play G4 at some point to restrict
the F5 break this early Knight H5 though
um of course prevents this move I mean
if I go here black happily prongs his
Knight into F4 and has a nice position
so um G4 is is nonsense here um aronian
played G3 which is a solid response
controlling this square and he tries to
actually evict this Knight with a yeah
slightly elaborate maneuver here Knight
H2 Bishop E2 and now attacking this
Knight and uh basically sending it back
so black has spent those Moves In order
to um get white to play some strange
moves on the king
side H4 yeah this really really intense
H5 the whole white setup is designed to
delay castling and sort of um Prof
prophylactically uh gain space on the
king side to um restrict red Black's
play yeah E4 was hanging so he covered
it yeah and now um we come to a funny
position um the question is um yeah what
about um The Pawn on B2 isn't Queen C2
um a normal move yeah it is but um take
a look at
this and um it's quite funny
black gets um gets the queen back in
this way and u wns a
pawn so it's not so easy to to actually
um pre um um cover this Pawn you can
play some passive move like Rook B1 but
um it's a question if this is really so
great it's not terrible but it's rather
passive aronian comes up with another
idea he simply ignores the
pawn and when V grabs
it he's quite well known for grabbing
lots of material if um it's not
immediately refutable it's not a bad
policy but
okay so white now took here and played
Knight A4 so all this was based on a
concrete um calculation in general um
you really um need to be cautious with
giving up your dark Square Bishop in the
king Zan as usually with pawns on white
squares in the center the dark Square
Bishop is very important to cover up
those those squares and uh without the
bishop you can very often get into
trouble here is not so terrible but um
you need to be cautious with um this
yeah and now black even gets
um nice Central position for the Queen
the only thing which is uh a problem is
that this queen doesn't have so many
moves let's say if white would go here
for example the queen wouldn't have any
move but
um something like this maybe could black
could black play
H now Knight
B6 yeah this leads to interesting
complications I wonder um how black
saved the queen
now you go here then Rook
D1 yeah this looks rather good for
white maybe Knight B6 Rook to
A6 taking the Knight so after Rook D1
Rook
B6 takes takes I don't know how this
way we have a weird position where black
has a rook and a minor piece for the
queen doesn't look um like it is enough
but it's not entirely
clear yeah I didn't do um a big analysis
um before I started video only a quick
uh overview um over the
games yeah maybe uh Queen C2 was was an
interesting alternative here what he
played didn't really led to much Knight
B6 Rook
A6 and drook
B1 yeah black is
um still this Pawn up but it's not
important really it's about those um
rather strangely positioned pieces I
mean this um Knight on B6 um restricts
Black's Rook this is uh the compensation
that white has this Rook doesn't have
any squares and uh it's not so easy for
black to get out of this without
returning
material yeah now white tries to
activate this Knight on H2 which which
was really a bad
piece yeah white took on C6 now it's um
probably a case where you you don't want
to really play this move because it um
potentially freeze The Rook here but U
maybe you don't have have anything
else you could think about um going
D6 not sure if this um this is good
this kind of Pawn advances
um also can lead into trouble Bishop um
to f8 um attacks it again can
here yeah maybe this was an alternative
it's interesting it's much sharper than
taking but it's also more risky what he
played um just taking is certainly
um a solid option I mean you could you
get C6 and probably even C5 yeah maybe
this is better advancing the de um was
maybe too
much Rook B8 takes here and Knight D7
yeah it looks like like a um somewhat
annoying pin but Rook C8
um gets rid of this and here in this
position white should be very very
slightly better because of the piece
activity but it's probably not enough to
get
anything yeah now black has um this
weakness to uh to attack at
least and The Rook gets active
check yeah after a couple more moves
this and it in a draw wow this this
looks really uh unnatural for black with
the bishop on h8 but um it's probably
not that that white can can do so much
he
also needs to watch the a pawn check
check yeah and um I guess we have some
sort of repetition
coming oops
A3 yeah and uh
the bishop is simply too too bad che
check will get
exchanged and now we trade down to this
end
game where um there's simply nothing
yeah and they agree to draw here yeah
black can black can just stay he doesn't
need to do anything just um play sort of
nothing moves and get the
draw okay um
Let's uh have a look at this Ivan zukov
against wanghao
yeah zukov plays the classical variation
the
Rubenstein against the nimzo and he um
has written an excellent book on this
the Strategic NSO Indian it is called
and uh we get the same line that wanghao
played against Ian shuk in the Olympia
in the last round where he lost the
crucial game against the Ukrainian ion
and um in this
game um Ivan shuk also played
A3 which um zokolov actually recommended
in his book and we have this again so
it's a theoretical duel really and um
RHA drops back to
D6 um if I remember correctly in um the
Ivano game he took on C3 and this is now
his Improvement now white plays E4 and
this is the point of the early
A3 um if you play A3 with castles and
Bishop B7 already played then you cannot
go E4 it is sufficiently um controlled
then in the Square now you manage to uh
get this Pawn at
once and we have um this
continuation yeah this is
um a bit uh looking like a Rubenstein
French actually Rubenstein has many
lines named after him it's um like the D
takes E4 variation in the French which
is um of course quite solid for black
but it's
um not not too exciting often but black
black has a healthy development cannot
um really speak of big troubles here for
black yeah white now took the chance to
um to capture on D6 at least getting the
bishop pair and after the recapture he
played Bishop f for yeah and um here
black
um decided to um immediately trade down
the game with E5 which is uh the most um
direct solution to equalize takes and
takes on F3 this was the idea Queen
takes and Knight E5 and now um this uh
double
attack leads to a further simplification
where black gets some one of those two
Bishops and D5 he immediately gets rid
of the weakness and um yeah this is very
um very solid and
um sound way to to go for black it's U
not terribly exciting but it gives you
gives you complete
equality
yeah now we basically trade
down and it's nothing uh nothing much
going on the Knight on D5 controls uh C7
nicely Black's
King goes uh towards the center and
there is simply nothing to play for I
think they they play a couple of moves
but uh there's really not much going on
white has um a slight um a slight
advantage nominally because of the
bishop which is um somewhat the better
oops wanted to do that somewhat the
better piece and it maybe can attack H6
and G5 but it's um simply not enough to
get anything um yeah anything tangable
going yeah white even gets a pass Pawn
here on G5 but Black's got um got a
blockade
yeah it still looks it looks somewhat
better for
white maybe there's some improvement
around
here if anything uh there's something
for white I mean black can only sit and
wait and um try to draw
this okay
took oops s this was was too quick Rook
A6 mhm
yeah A7 is um is a
problem like Rook takes A5 Bishop E3 and
then take on A7 this is probably why
black um is immediately trying to to
activate the the
Knight but he goes into
pin that this looks good for white but
what if um white
would would First
Take I don't know this looks tricky I'm
I'm pretty sure that around here maybe
zukov missed
something he had some time on the clock
still they both have been playing
relatively
quickly it's hard to tell I would need
much more time time to figure this out
but this looks like white white is
better with this bishop against the
Knight let's see how it how it
ended yeah okay this this cannot be the
the best way to play Rook H6 and then
all the way back okay it's probably good
enough to to draw the game but it looks
like a loss of time yeah and now black
probably gets gets this
Pawn Yeah and and drawn how could it
continue let's say Rook takes yeah white
would probably take here
here yeah and we have nothing on the
board it's a draw even if one of the
pawns would get lost yeah I think
somewhere around here I mean I'm not
sure I would would need to analyze it
more um more deeply maybe zokolov had
something it looks very
likely okay um what else did we have we
have uh yeah this is a strange one Leo
against
Lami you probably know Leo Lami maybe
not he's a very good Dutch
player and he has played already um in
VI in um previous
years
okay we have night off and Leo plays G3
which is um quite interesting way
actually to play against the night off
if you don't want to go for a big main
line then G3 um has its points it's um
more of a positional way to play but um
very often black players uh don't really
know what to do and have
problems okay E6 this transposes into a
kind of sking and setup
Knight
C6 yeah this looks um fairly normal but
I'm I'm no expert I must must admit that
Queen
E2 yeah what is a bit annoying for black
in this position is that the typical
pawn move move B5 um wasn't possible and
now with
A5 white um puts a bind here on the
queen
side so um black doesn't have any easy
counter play
there Knight D7 Rook do and now and now
something really strange happened and I
didn't really understand what was going
on I must
admit now um Rook E8 okay but um
somewhere here now exactly this move
Bishop to F6 and this uh I really um had
problems to to understand I mean if you
look at clock times Leo had spent some
time like 30 minutes and Lami also but
now he took uh like 30 minutes and then
played Bishop to F6 sacrificing a pawn
and um if you look at this in the game
it was really like no compensation at
all at least it looked like this to me
and um the question is is it really so
bad already that you need to play Bishop
F6 I don't
know it's really it's really a pawn I
mean it's
um I don't
know it's black so so wor so so bad here
I mean like Rook C8 or H6 or some sort
of waiting moves not like H6 is um
helping much but I mean look at the game
it's it's it really looks like um
a pawn for pretty much nothing maybe he
also miscalculated this is impossible of
course but this is just a pawn and white
also has got pressure on the defile he's
got this idea and black simply has got
nothing the Knight F6 and now Leo played
Knight C3 which is um of course quite a
logical move to get the Knight back into
into some play from the from the edge of
the board he however think what about F4
this was also
possibility just trying to kick them
kick the
queen something like
this
H yeah this also looks terrible for
black it's got offside Queen and
uh there's no attack whatsoever
something like this can just take
and then maybe put uh put this in a in a
pin even yeah it looks uh looks
terrible maybe F4 was the way to to
punish uh black directly after Knight C3
yeah black is also clearly worse but aha
he he prevented F4 now or i''s
say maybe he's not preventing it per se
but makes it more difficult for why to
to go for this
Queen
D4 and we got um Queen
exchange yeah white is still better but
um somehow um you have the feeling that
maybe White had had more along the way
maybe this F4 was uh was really
better
difficult okay and now black has got a
little bit of counter playay against the
the pawn on F4 and Knight H4 for yeah
still white is is better much better
but yeah I mean I think that there was
something something better if you need
to play such a passive move to protect
your
pawn something um wrong probably
happened
already yeah still a
pawn but now I think um black has chance
to to get it back so maybe um Queen D3
wasn't great yeah white was in some time
trouble
here
check yeah he turned the pawn but um
in um as a compensation white has got
ideas to invade with the Knight and has
got active pieces so it's still probably
somewhat better for white this is um
maybe why he returned the
pawn yeah of course um you need to get
rid of the D6 Knight cannot play against
this
piece
check yeah and um this looks U quite
drawish now
to be
honest yeah and
um check we had some some more exchanges
and uh check and the draw
coming
check yeah okay almost down to King
with's
King yeah it's a bit mysterious for me
um why black um decided to
really go for this I mean Grand Masters
or strong players are notoriously averse
to defending passive
positions um and he probably didn't want
to do that but um I believe if if you
really need to go here then you must
have played some terrible stuff before
and it didn't look so bad to me what
black played so maybe um Rook C8 or
something was was still bad
and here it just looks like white is
winning maybe maybe as mentioned this F4
IDM is is better I don't know so Leo
certainly missed a big chance here to
get uh get a point for the start okay um
I now went through five games which all
ended in a draw and um I saved the
two um two other games for last we
actually had some some
result um yeah we've got kakin playing
White against um Chinese yeah for former
you need to say former now former world
champion women world champion
H and we had one E4 yeah whoan is making
his his her her of course Deb in um in
really Top Class um yeah
usually Men Tournament um and it will be
very difficult for her you can say this
uh before beforehand even she's very
strong 2,600 and she is probably also
stronger than 2,600 but uh it's uh still
very difficult to play all those uh top
guys she probably doesn't have the
preparation and and everything to to
combat this okay let's see what happens
in the first game kakin goes nice C3 and
we have this classical zilian
again the same position as in Anand
against
Nakamura uh but now instead of the very
normal move Knight C6 who he found
played Bishop E7 which probably um yeah
could be a simple transposition if you
look at uh this bishop E3 and now Knight
C6 would lead to the um already
mentioned line that is popular
nowadays but here she played B6 which is
a a move that I never saw here but I'm
not an expert must uh must must say um
yeah maybe it is interesting it's
um difficult to tell I didn't check if
this has been played a lot or um this
idea to play B6 in these structures um
is not not new there's for example just
to put put it on the board Knight C6
Queen D2
castles there's something like this for
example where black um protects C5 so
that after capture he would be able to
recapture with the pawn and have a very
very good position and now um yeah she's
playing this move uh very early also
getting this idea into
play so Bishop E2
and Bishop A6 she immediately went for
this probably this is um this is a new
idea or at least a very rare idea um it
has one drawback and this is um yeah the
time loss involved we see what happens
castles she now took and this is
important white captured with the
Knight we see why is important Knight C6
and now the very thematic move C C4 and
I believe actually that after C4 black
already is in quite serious
trouble maybe black needed to address
this um this C4 idea here already and um
play something
else I'm not sure what to be
honest um the problem is that C4 opens
up um the position very quickly on the
light squares and you have um weakened
the light Square with this B6 C5 setup
we'll see what uh what I'm talking about
maybe black here needs to do something
else I don't know maybe this kind of
idea to strengthen D5 just an idea let's
see what happens in the game to to show
what I'm talking about
C4 she now took and D5 and this is the
problem look at this now white has a
very strong Queen on D5 he will get this
back probably with the queen and then
there are all kinds of ideas to use the
white squares in the center and E6 is an
idea on all those pieces are yeah they
don't have secure
posts yeah and now white simply
threatens to um strengthen the position
further Rook D1 Knight C3 this kind of
normal moves or even E6 at some
point yeah she tried the radical
B5 the idea being if white would
take then Knight C2 is a
for but of course um white can simply
centralize the queen this
way controlling the key squares of
Black's Knight and um improve his
position yeah black um decided to get
rid of the centralized Queen but in the
process gave away B5
check she G she got it back with Rook B8
B2 but now we see what what I mentioned
before the Knight is on D5 and Black's
King on d8 so simply um a terrible
position Rook
D1 and white um piles up on the king and
uh
it's very difficult now the Knight comes
to
C4 or E4 for that matter even
better check yeah it's simply a huge
attack and um black has um I think
almost no way to avoid material losses
she tried the I think the best possible
with Rook G8 attacking the
sensitive G2 Square but white
could go go like this and now white
simply threatens Knight to F6 or
taking and um black will lose um
material as there's also Knight C3 we
see what happens she took now Che and
now this Knight before check wins The
Rook it's no blunder really it looks
maybe like one but um black really
doesn't have a move if black would for
instance go here Knight C5 and now we've
got Knight F6 as threat and and uh Rook
takes
C6 there is no
defense so it's simply the bad position
of the king and those uh yeah unstable
Knights check okay at the end
check check yeah black has got has got
something here at the end there's the G2
um oops the G2 threat and this actually
wins back some
material
check
check yeah white has an extra piece need
some um some slight
accuracy of course the H Pawn you
shouldn't give away that that one but
kayin is an excellent technical player
and um there wasn't really going on
much
check yeah he simply attacks the
weaknesses and they cannot be
defended yeah now black resigned yeah
this was
um kind of a strange game actually if
you look at this you've got um this B6
which is a new um or maybe rare um
opening idea obviously um something you
need to prepare before the game kakin
plays this line Knight E3 E5 it's no uh
surprise and if you look at
this I mean after 11 moves the game is
basically
over this is a position that U probably
a top Grand Master um considers to be
close to
winning how should um black defend the
center it's very uh very difficult um
just to to illustrate if if black let's
say would castle Yeah okay I need
to actually go
back I want to show really how bad this
is it it's probably not looking so
terrible at first side but in the game
she took and then you've got this D5 but
let's say let's say black would Castle
just to put it on the board then white
would take and go here and how do you
protect this
Pawn even B6 is a will move you cannot
go Knight B6 now this Knight cannot go
anywhere the best line probably is to
take and then D5 is terribly weak white
also has got Knight F5 all in all you
see the white squares are completely
weak and this is all due to the bishop
A6 um idea which isn't um a terrible
idea in itself in the French but it very
often um is problematic if white would
open the center quickly and we have
exactly this position here where white
manages to do that so very strange
preparation by black I mean you can if
you look at this you can you can really
discard the line after Knight E2 unless
you find some improvement so it's a very
strange uh piece of preparation or she's
just stumbled into this don't know and
both um doesn't sound too great after 10
moves okay so and uh we've got one game
left and this is um the the Indian
grandm Hari Krishna he's I think number
two of India after vishy um against
Anish giri the Dutch um
talent and um yeah yet another French I
only had a look at the end game here but
not uh not the beginning okay we got a
Rubenstein French quite um surprisingly
know that giri was playing this and uh
G3 yeah this is a
very positional line of course intending
to go uh to G2 and use the bishop on the
long
diagonal yeah white um has went with
Rook to D1 to get this typical
opposition Rook against Queen and to
make it more difficult for black to play
C5 yeah this is quite um typical
position for this opening for black it's
very
solid and um he decided to simplify even
more with taking one E5 the problem was
of course that this Knight is
potentially going to C6 which really uh
would yeah would freeze up Black's
position
cannot go Rook d8 you cannot allow a
knight to C6 therefore he he just
chopped it
off and
um yeah in this position is hard to
imagine that U white should have um a
serious um plus black is
U super solid
here and we got some further
exchange okay and now
now there's um slightly weakened Pawn
but
probably yeah not sure black has got the
defile not sure how how bad this
is
check oh wow
interesting yeah I didn't look
beforehand as
mentioned quite quite a cool tactic
coming yeah white cannot protect uh this
uh this um Bishop really there's stuff
like this
oops and uh if you would use the king
you have Rook
D4 Black is Black is winning even it's
really um super annoying
pin so um yeah you get to get the piece
back with Rook
D1 and we got into a rook end game
mhm with
um equal material but where white has
maybe slightly more active position with
Rook D7 and the King being a bit more
active of course um this is a weakness
but um it's not easy to
use take use
of yeah black needs to be um I think
precise
this Rook is uh quite
strong guarantee gave away the pawn if
black would uh would cover it I think
white would probably simply
um approach with this King and um The
Rook isn't really in a great
shape so he gave away this pawn it
wasn't the Great this Pawn
anyway yeah now black tries to simplify
I mean the only thing that he needs to
accomplish here probably not uh that
easy but uh if he would exchange off the
whole Queens side pawns then it's
obviously completely dead I mean three
against two with this double Pawn is
nothing so uh black wants to
simplify exactly C6 and
B5 this looks like the way to do
it and A4 mhm okay yeah this is probably
a good response it sort of um make sure
that the Rook is uh looking somewhat
stupid on
C5
took yeah and drook F5 not sure if you
needed to do
that what if black would place something
like this ah there's Rook E5 this is the
idea okay yeah this is a problem not
sure if you want to allow that giving
white the pawn I think something similar
happens in the game look
F5
check yeah white now threatening Rook f8
winning so black drops back and now
white switches his attention toh to the
A5
pawn and maybe he's threatening to come
along this
way yeah G6 is
um
well
I'm a bit um I'm a bit
um shocked that black really played C6
uh G6
yeah giving white um a pass
Pawn was this really necessary or is
this some some sort of zuk Swang I mean
why why not
taking it's something like this and then
giving checks
here
yeah it's it's not uh not great this
position of obviously but I would I
would think that G6
helps white maybe I'm wrong but um it
looks like like
helpful
check
check yeah now white forces this um this
trans transformation black um took here
he cannot um not not take
here
check as white is far too quick with
taking here and advancing the H
Pawn
check yeah and now we've
got the the a pawn and the F Pawn and
this is a rather dangerous combination
we will see uh See this
later
yeah and now um this is a pretty
interesting um yeah formation that you
should pay attention to if in this kind
of situation where we've got the a pawn
with the rook in front of it the problem
is that black of course um cannot go
here because of Rook h8 this is the
important trick
check getting the
Rook so the problem is that black really
cannot move his King to the f file this
of course is is even
simpler so black needs to sort
of yeah stay on G7 and H7 he can in this
situation push the C Pawn but white just
approaches with the King and uh the
problem is that white simply pushes the
F Pawn and provokes um Black's King on
some square that he really doesn't like
let's say C3 and uh oh it's even um it's
even a white winds attached to this he
resigned while playing this probably
yeah white just goes here and uh the
problem is the C Pawn doesn't really
matter in this position black is in zuk
Swang if he goes something like here
white simp simply pushes the F Pawn at
the board check and now it's it's over
it's
this winning The
Rook or taking check and white promotes
so this is important uh Motif the
combination of the a pawn and F Pawn is
very powerful because it um it helps why
to promote the a pawn really if uh it
wasn't for the F Pawn it wouldn't be
winning um yeah so an interesting uh win
here for Hari Krishna out of a very very
um let's say
uh yeah like I don't know I mean this
looks like not
much yeah just just just for instance if
you think about this position and uh
let's say you would take away the H Pawn
Yeah white has an extra Pawn but let's
imagine he didn't wouldn't have the H2
Pawn isn't this just the same position
and white won this it's not exactly the
same position of course but the H Pawn
has some some importance on H2 but it's
very very little and he managed to win
this um I still I'm not sure about this
G6 move um
but
yeah hard to tell without any deep
analysis so okay um what did we have
here we had um seven games uh five draws
and two decisive games um there have
been some chances that um maybe weren't
realized for zukov against
swanga and
um Leo against Lami was certainly
winning at some point but he somehow
didn't uh manage to to do it and the two
wins yeah one was kind of an opening
disaster for how you fun
she um yeah played some weird line in
the French and got got really rolled
over by um
kayin and um we had this game harri
Krishna against gir where harri Krishna
showed a great endgame technique by
winning uh winning this position
probably um giri could have uh defended
better I don't think you should really
lose this position but obviously it uh
it wasn't wasn't so easy at least I
cannot um yeah off hand tell where his
mistake was yeah thanks for watching I
hope you like this kind of video where I
look at all the games quickly if there
is some great highlight video that uh
highlight game that merits um more
in-depth um investigation in the
upcoming rounds are also do the kind of
one game one video thing but um I felt
this complete overview was also quite
interesting yeah I hope you liked it
I'll be back soon with the round two
probably of Tata
Steel